Hello, listener. This is Jason Bateman along with Will Arnett and Sean Hayes for the podcast called Smart List. If that's a place you're looking for, you've found it. Congratulations. It's not a real high concept podcast. One person invites a guest, the other two don't know who that guest is, and then we chat. Here we go. Jason, let me just ask you something. I know that you're a fan of energy bars and that kind of thing. Is there a part of you that goes, maybe I should just eat some whole foods and not just eat stuff that they have at the space station? Are you going to this bathroom constantly? It helps me because you know I'm on the go.
你好，听众朋友们。我是杰森·贝特曼，还有威尔·阿奈特和肖恩·海斯，欢迎收听播客《聪明清单》。如果你正在寻找这样的节目，那你找对地方了。恭喜你。这不是那种概念很大的播客。一个人邀请一位嘉宾，另外两个人都不知道嘉宾是谁，然后我们就开始聊天。我们开始吧。杰森，我先问你个问题。我知道你是能量棒这类东西的粉丝。你心里有没有那么一刻会想，也许我应该吃点天然食品，而不是只吃那些太空站里才有的东西？你是不是频繁跑厕所？这对我很有帮助，因为你知道我一直都在忙。
I'm just, I'm not. You must be. It sounds like an ad, but you got to stop. Sometimes when I don't have the time to eat the way I want to eat, I grab a think bar. You're on the go and they make you go. I bet a lot. Sure. Well, it's exactly. All doors are swinging open and closed at various times. Will called me today. He was watching soccer and I was like, champions, champions. But he can hang on. He calls it football like a real douche bag. It's football. It's football.
我只是，我没有。你一定有。听起来像个广告，但你得停下来。有时当我没时间按照自己想要的方式进食时，我会拿一根 Think 棒。你在忙，它们让你去。我敢打赌很多。当然。嗯，完全是这样。各种时间里，所有的门都在开开关关。威尔今天给我打电话。他当时在看足球，我就说，冠军，冠军。但他能坚持。他像个真正的混蛋一样管它叫足球。是足球。是足球。
And I was like, I got off the phone with you. I was like, you know why I don't watch that is because it's like, oh, there's two minutes left in the game and it's one to one. I can't wait to see who breaks the time. Back with baseball. Will, if I may, you have to get engrossed in the game of it as opposed to the sport of it. There is strategy. There is enjoyment in the pacing of it. They call it, they call a soccer or what you call a soccer, I call it football. They call it the beautiful game. So you watch, there's a, you watch the way that the team, the shape that they get.
然后我就想，我挂了你的电话。我当时就想，你知道为什么我不看那个吗，因为就像是，哦，比赛还剩两分钟，比分是一比一。我等不及看谁打破僵局了。回到棒球。威尔，恕我直言，你必须沉浸在比赛的博弈中，而不是把它当成一项单纯的运动。这里面有策略。比赛节奏本身就充满了乐趣。他们称之为，他们管足球叫，或者你管足球叫，我管它叫足球。他们称之为美丽的比赛。所以你看，有一种，你看着球队的这种，他们排出的阵型。
So our guest today, our guest today. Darry, you cut me off. Sean, if you, so for monkeys that are high on sugar like you that need to see a lot of scoring, these things wouldn't be right. You might, you might like the, something with a shot clock in it, like basketball or a play clock like football. Football. Yeah. I really enjoy watching football. You want to see a thousand point scored every game. Score, score, score, score, score, score, score, score.
所以我们今天的嘉宾，我们今天的嘉宾。达里，你打断了我。肖恩，如果你，所以对于像你这样糖分上头、需要看到大量进球的猴子来说，这些东西可能不合适。你可能会，你可能会喜欢带进攻计时器的东西，比如篮球，或者带比赛计时器的橄榄球。橄榄球。对。我真的很喜欢看橄榄球。你希望每场比赛都得一千分。得分，得分，得分，得分，得分，得分，得分，得分。
That's what's fun. We're done. Yeah. I'm sorry. It's not as exciting as golf. All right. So listen, our guest today has excelled in literally every facet of the entertainment business. He's a superstar actor, producer, writer, director. He starred as an actor in some of my favorite TV shows and he's directed all of my favorite movies as a human being this guy. He's so much more than his credits. So let me just say his name so we can freak out and then I want to get into all his brilliance. It's the amazing, you guys know him. You worked
这才是好玩的地方。我们说完了。对。我很抱歉。这可没高尔夫那么刺激。好啦。听着，我们今天的嘉宾在娱乐行业的方方面面都取得了卓越的成就。他是巨星演员、制片人、编剧、导演。他作为演员主演过我最喜欢的一些电视剧，他还执导了我所有最喜欢电影，作为一个真正的人，这家伙。他远不止他所取得的成就。所以让我直接说出他的名字，好让我们惊呼一下，然后我想深入了解他的所有才华。这就是了不起的，你们都知道他。你们跟他合作过
with them. Ron Howard. What? Ron. How did you keep this a secret? Hey guys. Oh, I'm so excited you're here. Right?
。朗·霍华德。什么？朗。你是怎么把这事保密的？嘿，伙计们。哦，我太高兴你们能来了。对吧？
I'm going to get you. Hey, man. Hello, buddy. Great to see you guys. Good. And by the way, I like a shot clock and baseball. Yes. Okay.
我要抓住你。嘿，老兄。你好，老弟。很高兴见到你们。很好。顺便说一句，我喜欢计时器和棒球。对。好吧。
Okay. Where do you fall on soccer or football? I have come to really appreciate soccer slash football mostly because I worked in Europe so much. I want to actually go into games there. So good, right? And in England, you know, they go nuts and you sort of get caught up. Did you learn how to sing any of those songs in the stands? You're like, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right, right,
好吧。你对英式足球或美式足球怎么看？我开始真正欣赏足球/英式足球，主要是因为我在欧洲工作了很长时间。我其实想去那里的比赛现场。太棒了，对吧？在英国，你知道，他们会疯狂呐喊，你不知不觉就被卷进去了。你有没有学会唱看台上的那些歌？你会觉得，对，对，对，对，对，对，对，对，对，对，对，
right, right, right. You've got the first course down. Right. That was the most gregarious I've ever seen you. So look at, I want to know, by the way, the movies, right? I know we all kind of know each other. I don't know you as well as Will and Jason do, but they don't really know me. Nobody knows Ron. Nobody.
对。你已经学会第一段副歌了。没错。那是我见过你最热情奔放的一次。所以看，我想知道，顺便说一句，电影，对吧？我知道我们大家都挺了解彼此的。我对你的了解不如威尔和杰森深，但他们其实并不真正了解我。没人真正了解朗。没人。
Nobody knows him. Nobody knows him. That's what this episode is about. But like, I grew up like literally when I say you directed all of my favorite movies, you directed all of my favorite movies, Night Shift, I can quote all those like Cocoon, Backdraft, Apollo 13, Beautiful Mind, Solo, A Star Wars Story. Here we go. One of my favorite like movies of the series. And by the way, let me just get this out of the way. Is there going to be a sequel to Solo or not?
没人了解他。没人了解他。这就是本期节目的主题。但是，我是在什么时候长大的，说真的，当我，你说你执导了我所有最喜欢的电影时，你确实执导了我所有最喜欢的电影，比如《夜班巡逻》，我能引述所有这些台词，比如《茧》、《烈火雄心》、《阿波罗13号》、《美丽心灵》、《游侠索罗：星球大战外传》。我们来了。我最喜欢的系列电影之一。顺便说一句，让我先把这个解决了。《游侠索罗》会有续集吗？
Duo. I love that movie. I love that movie. Yeah, I think, I don't think there's going to be a sequel. I think the gangster universe could wind up being considered for Disney plus. I mean, I think it's a great world, a great character, but nothing in it, nothing in it that I'm aware of. But Ron, you should be 97 years old with all of the movies that you've directed. I mean, it's supposed, it takes about a year to do a movie all in if you're really going, right?
二人组。我喜欢那部电影。我喜欢那部电影。是的，我想，我觉得不会有续集。我认为黑帮宇宙最终可能会被迪士尼+考虑。我的意思是，我认为这是一个伟大的世界，一个伟大的角色，但里面没有什么，没有什么是我知道的。但是朗，以你执导过的所有电影来看，你应该已经97岁了。我的意思是，如果你真的全力以赴的话，拍一部电影大约需要一年时间，对吧？
He's 96, by the way. How do you get it all done and still have this incredible family that you have? And how do you do it? Well, I mean, thanks. I started when I was four. But I mean, but the directing part, I mean, you can cram in a bunch of acting stuff. You can work in three, four, five, six movies a year, but to direct one, you got to just do the one. Well, that pretty much takes over. I mean, in recent years, I've started also doing documentaries
顺便说一句，他今年96岁。你是怎么把这一切都搞定，还能拥有这样一个令人难以置信的家庭的？你是怎么做到的？好吧，我的意思是，谢谢。我四岁就开始了。但我的意思是，导演的部分，我的意思是你可以塞进一堆表演工作。你一年可以参演三、四、五、六部电影，但要导演一部，你必须专心致志地只拍那一部。好吧，那几乎占据了全部。我的意思是，近年来，我开始同时做纪录片
kind of at the same time that I'm doing the scripted work. Poverati. I saw Poverati. It was amazing. I love that documentary. Oh, thank you. Thanks. And I'm finding them really fascinating. And that is a totally different rhythm. And in fact, I love kind of shifting from the editing room or going over a set of questions, you know, based on that subject and then jumping back into the scripted. But also, imagine entertainment has just made it so possible for me to move a number of projects along, working with great executives, working, of course, with Brian Grazer to just get stuff
和我正在做的剧本创作工作。帕瓦罗蒂。我看了《帕瓦罗蒂》。太棒了。我喜欢那部纪录片。哦，谢谢。谢谢。我发现它们真的很吸引人。而且那完全是另一种节奏。事实上，我喜欢从剪辑室抽身出来，或者根据这个主题过一遍问题清单，然后又跳回剧本创作中。但同时，想象娱乐公司（Imagine Entertainment）也让我能够非常顺利地推进多个项目，与优秀的行政人员合作，当然还有与布莱恩·格雷泽合作，把事情
done. Imagine entertainment is the name of your production company. And you make two shows and movies, yeah. Yes. And that, which we, Mitch Hurwitz loved to skewer on the rest of the film. And excuse, Sean will, at various points in this interview, he will stop and he'll start explaining the obvious because he feels that it's incumbent upon him to explain to our audience member. Specifically, his sister or niece or daughter-in-law in Wisconsin or in Wisconsin, I don't want
搞定。“想象娱乐”是你制作公司的名字。你们制作电视节目和电影，对吧？是的。而这个，我们，米奇·赫维茨喜欢在《发展受阻》里拿它开涮。不好意思，肖恩会在这次访谈的不同时间点停下来，开始解释显而易见的事情，因为他觉得他有责任向我们的观众解释。具体来说，是他在威斯康星州的姐姐、侄女或儿媳妇，或者在威斯康星州，我不想
anybody from the heartland to be confused. I don't want that. Ron, I like you. Consider the audience. Yes. Yeah. But while we're on Imagine, can I- Well, tell everybody too, Jason, what that Imagine and why you know Ron. Well, Will and I know Ron because he was nice enough to put us on a rest of development and basically give us both careers.
让任何心脏地带的人感到困惑。我不想那样。朗，我喜欢你。要考虑观众。没错。是的。但趁我们还在谈“想象”，我能——好吧，杰森，也告诉大家那是什么，“想象”以及你为什么认识朗。嗯，威尔和我认识朗是因为他人很好，让我们上了《发展受阻》，基本上给了我们两人的职业生涯。
True. But I took the opportunity to talk and wine and dine Ron as much as possible to pick his brain about how he has done what he has done with his career because it is a North Star that I try to stay pointed towards as much as possible. I'm just in awe of your ability to not only stay prolific, but relevant. I mean, a lot of people stay busy, but they don't always stay relevant and your ability to diversify from an actor to a director to a producer and I just, there's not really a question in here. It's just for the audience, just know this is, this man is it to me.
真的。但我抓住机会尽可能多地与朗交谈、吃吃喝喝，以探究他是如何用自己的职业生涯做到这一点的，因为这是我尽量保持对齐的北极星。我非常敬佩你不仅能保持高产，还能保持热度。我的意思是，很多人都很忙，但他们并不总能保持热度，而你从演员转型为导演再到制片人的多样化能力，我只是，这里其实没有什么问题。只是对观众来说，要知道这一点，这个人在我看来就是一切。
Yeah. So pardon me if I get a little goofy during today's interview. No, no. There, the question in there might be, you know, when you, when did you know you wanted to be a director and did you, did any part of that path, did you choose that path because you saw the shelf life of some actors and wanted to get out ahead of it or- And also like, do you think now, sorry to get this like a three-prong question, but did you now having done all that and being such an example and being the gold standard and is it worth it when you have to have all these meals with Jason Bateman and he asks
是的。所以如果我在今天的访谈中表现得有点傻，请原谅我。不，不。那里的问题可能是，你知道，当你在，你什么时候知道你想当导演的，而且你是否，那个道路的任何一部分，你选择这条路是因为你看到了某些演员的保质期并想走在它前面，还是——还有，你现在觉得，抱歉问了这样一个三管齐下的问题，但是你现在做完了这一切，成为这样一个榜样，成为黄金标准，当你必须和杰森·贝特曼吃所有这些饭，而他问你
you how to do it? Does it almost make it like, fuck, I wish I'd just done nothing. So I didn't have to listen to his bullshit questions about like, how he cravenly asks you, how did you do it? That's the secret. You know, it's always a yin and yang thing. You take the bad with the good. No, the, look, first of all, you guys, Howard Morris, you know who Howard Morris was from Sid Caesar shows and your show shows and one of those brilliant guys who along with Carl Reiner and Sid kind of defined sketch comedy.
怎么做时，这一切还值得吗？这会不会让你觉得，操，我真希望自己什么都没做。这样我就不用听他那些废话连篇的问题了，比如他怎么卑躬屈膝地问你，你是怎么做到的？这就是秘诀。你知道，这总是阴阳结合的。有坏就有好。不，看，首先，你们知道的，霍华德·莫里斯，你知道霍华德·莫里斯是谁吗，来自西德·凯撒的节目和你的秀，他是那些与卡尔·雷纳和西德一起定义了小品喜剧的才华横溢的人之一。
Sure. Well, he was a brilliant guy, hilariously funny. He played Ernest T. Bass on the Andy Griffith show. He was this hillbilly who would come to town and wreak havoc and of course had nothing to do with who the real Howard Morris was, but he created this character. But he also then started directing and almost all of the directors on the Andy Griffith show had been actors. Some of them directed like a whole season's work. Some of them would just come and go a little like Howard Morris or Richard Crenna, you know, people like that. And Andy always liked that. And when I was about eight or nine, I was a massive movie
当然。嗯，他是个才华横溢的人，极其搞笑。他在《安迪·格里菲斯秀》中扮演欧内斯特·T·巴斯。他是那种会来到镇上大肆破坏的乡巴佬，这当然和真正的霍华德·莫里斯是谁毫无关系，但他创造了这个角色。但后来他也开始导演，而且《安迪·格里菲斯秀》几乎所有的导演都是演员。他们中有的人导演了一整季的作品，有的人只是来来去去，有点像霍华德·莫里斯或理查德·克雷纳，你知道，诸如此类的人。安迪总是喜欢那样。当我八九岁的时候，我已经是一个巨大的电影
star already. I've been in a couple of movies, but he was directing and we did, we did this scene where I was supposed to be in a car jammed in with everybody and he kept saying, move over, Ronnie, move over. And I was like jammed up against the doorknob and it was in my ribs. And I was kind of saying it's in my ribs. And he said, good, when you're in pain, you know, you're on your mark, but when it was all over, he said, you know, you are so curious and interested in all of this stuff. I'll bet you wind up being a director. I'll just bet you do.
明星了。我演过几部电影，但他在导演，我们拍了，我们拍了这样一场戏，我本该坐在一辆挤满人的车里，他一直说，往里挪挪，罗尼，往里挪挪。我当时被挤在门把手上，它顶着我的肋骨。我有点说它顶着我的肋骨。他说，很好，当你感到痛苦时，你知道你在你的位置上了，但当这一切结束时，他说，你知道，你对所有这些事情都充满好奇和兴趣。我敢打赌你最终会成为一名导演。我敢打赌你会的。
And I used to watch my dad who never directed film, but he directed theater. And you know, so I was at a certain point, I was so intrigued by everything that went on around the show. The writers, I was allowed to be in those read throughs and those and those story discussions afterward, you know, not in fact, now I'm going on for just a sec. That's your job on this. Okay. Okay. Good. In the beginning, I mean, the actors would be allowed to hang around for a half hour after a read through and offer up notes. And then Andy would stay with the and Don Knotts would stay with the writers and deepen the discussion. But every once
我经常看我爸爸，他从未执导过电影，但他导演戏剧。所以你知道，在某个特定阶段，我对节目周围发生的一切都着迷极了。编剧们，我被允许参加那些剧本围读会，以及之后的故事讨论，你知道，其实，现在我要说一秒钟。那是你在这节目里的工作。好吧。好吧。很好。一开始，我的意思是，演员们在剧本围读会后可以在现场逗留半小时，提出意见。然后安迪会和，唐·诺茨会和编剧留下来，深入讨论。但是每隔
in a while in that first year, when I was six, I actually did try to like make a suggestion and they never took them. I was a little irked by this, just a little peed, but I didn't let on. And then I remember in the second episode of the second season, I had just turned seven and we were rehearsing. And my job is to kind of run into the courthouse, swing the door open. Otis the drunk was over there with Barney and Andy. Of course, everybody's just in their regular clothes. We're just rehearsing with Scripps. And my job was to come and say, Hey, Paul, something. I don't know what the something was, but I was supposed to say something. And then I sort of hesitated and the director who had been an actor, Bob
一段时间，在那第一年，当我六岁的时候，我其实尝试过提出建议，但他们从来不接受。我对此有点恼火，就一点点生气，但我没有表现出来。然后我记得在第二季的第二集，我刚满七岁，我们正在排练。我的工作是跑进法院，推开门。酒鬼奥蒂斯和巴尼、安迪在那里。当然，每个人都穿着便服。我们只是拿着剧本排练。我的工作是进来然后说，嘿，保罗，什么什么的。我不知道那个什么是什么，但我得说点什么。然后我犹豫了一下，当过演员的导演鲍勃
Sweeney said, What is it? And I said, Well, I don't think a kid would say the line that way. And he said, Well, how do you think a kid would say it? And I pitched whatever my rewrite was. And he said, Great, say it that way. Let's go. And I was just stunned. I was a part of it, you know, I thought, and across from across the courthouse, Andy said, What are you grinning at, young man? And he actually did talk that way. And, and, and I said, Well, that's the first idea of mine you've taken. And he said, he said, Well, it was the first one that was any damn good. Now let's run the thing. I was able to be a part of this show and be a part of this process, which included the camera operators
·斯威尼说，怎么了？我说，嗯，我觉得小孩子不会那样说这句台词。他说，好吧，你觉得小孩子会怎么说？我提出了我的改写方案，不管是什么。他说，太棒了，就那样说。我们开始吧。我当时惊呆了。我是其中的一部分，你知道，我以为，从法庭的对面，安迪说，年轻人，你咧着嘴笑什么呢？他确实是那样说话的。而且，而且，我说，嗯，这是你采纳我的第一个主意。他说，他说，嗯，这是唯一一个像样的好主意。现在我们把这段过一遍。我能够成为这个节目的一部分，并成为这个过程的一部分，其中包括摄像师
and all of it. And at a certain point, I realized that the director was the one who kind of got to hang with everybody, kind of got to play with everybody. And I just became intrigued. So literally by the time that show did end when I was 14 years old, I had a fallen in love with movies and began to understand the difference between an episode of the Andy Griffith show or leave it to beaver and the graduates. And, and I understood this was a lot about the filmmaking. And I began to know that I really wanted to chase that. Did you ever end up directing any happy days? I didn't. I was offered chances to direct happy days at certain points because they knew I wanted to direct. In fact, I was in
以及所有这一切。在某个时刻，我意识到导演是那个能和所有人混在一起、能和所有人一起玩的人。我只是变得着迷。所以到那个节目在我14岁结束时，我已经爱上了电影，并开始理解《安迪·格里菲斯秀》或《留给比弗》与《毕业生》之间的区别。而且，我明白这在很大程度上关乎电影制作。我开始知道我真的很想追求那个。你最后有没有导演过任何《欢乐时光》？我没有。在某些时候，他们曾邀请我导演《欢乐时光》，因为他们知道我想导演。事实上，当这个节目开播时，我在
film school when the show started. And I had, I left USC film school and I thought it would just be like a one year gig because how many series really run, but it kept going. Jerry Parris was such a genius. And in all honesty, I never wanted to rob the rest of the cast of a week with Jerry for me. And then the other thing was I was wise enough to know that if I did a good job on a three camera episode of happy days, a show that I was in, it wasn't going to be a giant feather in my cap for my real dream, which was to direct signal camera and answer your other question one more time. So the thing is, once I did start directing and I did realize I truly loved it and I could do it. And I once I had
电影学院。我离开了南加州大学电影学院，我以为这只是一年的工作，因为到底有多少连续剧能真正长盛不衰呢，但它一直在继续。杰里·帕里斯真是个天才。老实说，我从来不想为了我而剥夺其他演员和杰里共度一周的机会。然后另一件事是，我足够聪明，知道如果我在一档我参演的《欢乐时光》的三机位剧本中表现出色，对于我真正的梦想——导演单机位来说，这不会成为我帽子上一根巨大的羽毛。回答你的另一个问题。所以事情是这样的，一旦我开始导演，我意识到我真的很爱它，而且我能做到。而且一旦我
left happy days and I was beginning to have success, you know, what night shift and then splash, I became a little bit anxious about it. Like, what would I choose next? Should I slow down? What should I do? And it just struck me that I love to work. I like all kinds of movies. I didn't want to be typecast as a director in the way that I sort of justifiably was as an actor. But I then said, you know, when we do an episode, it was season, 24 episodes it was then, we know they're not all going to be great. The idea is to make as many of them as great as they can be and to have as few of them that actually misfire and stink. Play for the average.
离开了《欢乐时光》并开始取得成功，你知道，通过《夜班巡逻》和《现代美人鱼》，我对此变得有点焦虑。比如，我接下来该选择什么？我应该放慢脚步吗？我该怎么做？这让我突然意识到我热爱工作。我喜欢各种各样的电影。我不想像我作为演员那样被理所当然地贴上某种类型片的导演标签。但我随后说，你知道，当我们制作一集时，那是赛季，当时是24集，我们知道它们不可能都很好。我们的想法是尽可能让其中尽可能多的集数变得精彩，并让那些真正失误和糟糕的集数尽可能少。为平均水平而战。
Play for the average. And I literally convinced myself that I wanted this to be my career and my way of life. So it wasn't so much about bespoke gems without a lifetime of creativity. And then you didn't have to be precious in that way. Probably relieved a lot of pressure. Right. Let me, you know, I wonder if, you know, you grew up, you know, you're talking about being six or seven on the Andy Griffith Show and then you were on happy days and, you know, you grew up on television and in movies. And I wonder if there is that idea, do you think not being precious was kind of a result of being, of understanding, you grew up in a
为平均水平而战。我真的说服了自己，希望这能成为我的职业和生活方式。所以这不那么像是为了没有一生创造力的量身定制的瑰宝。然后你就不必那么矫情了。这可能缓解了很多压力。对。让我，你知道，我想知道，你成长过程中，你知道，你谈到在《安迪·格里菲斯秀》里六七岁，然后你演了《欢乐时光》，你知道，你在电视和电影中长大。我想知道是否有这种想法，你认为不矫情是不是理解的结果，你从小在一个非常成人的世界里长大。
very adult world from a young age. And so you understood, I mean, that's a very kind of mature thought to have. Sometimes people don't have that thought. The idea of like, I don't need to be so precious doesn't come until you're 50 or 60 where you kind of go, all the stuff that I thought was so important when I was 25 is kind of ridiculous. And I've been holding on to this weird notion. Do you think that that was the benefit of having grown up in an adult world? Adult world and television. And television.
所以你懂得了，我的意思是，那是一种非常成熟的想法。有时人们没有这种想法。那种“我不需要那么矫情”的想法，直到你50或60岁时才会出现，那时你才会有点觉得，所有那些我在25岁时认为如此重要的事情其实挺荒谬的。而我一直抓着这个奇怪的观念不放。你认为那是成长于成人世界的益处吗？成人世界和电视界。以及电视界。
Yeah. People who come through television and don't develop really bad habits, and I'm so grateful. My dad was like a world-class coach and teacher and the spirit around that show was not a sitcom rhythm exactly and tone. Also the Andy Griffith Show in particular. I did learn more about bigger, harder comedy with happy days, especially when it went in front of a live audience. And I really learned about that. But, you know, people who go through that television pace, the rigors of that, you guys know this. And I see it in your work. And Jason, I see it when you're either in front of or behind the camera. It's a confidence
是的。那些经历过电视界而没有养成真正坏习惯的人，我非常感激。我父亲是一位世界级的教练和老师，那个节目周围的精神并不完全是情景喜剧的节奏和基调。尤其是《安迪·格里菲斯秀》。我在《欢乐时光》里学到了更多关于更大、更硬核的喜剧的知识，特别是当它在现场观众面前表演时。我真的学到了很多。但是，你知道，经历过那种电视节奏、那种严酷考验的人，你们都懂。我在你们的工作中看到了这一点。杰森，当你在镜头前或镜头后时，我也看到了这一点。这是一种自信
that your taste, your instincts that you can trust your gut and your batting average will be higher than most. And if you need help, you'll look around and get it because you don't have a lot of times of wasting. And let's get to the bottom of this and solve it. And you begin to trust that rhythm. And of course, that's what I grew up with. So, you know, when I'm shooting, I like to shoot at a pretty good pace. I like to, you know, I like to have an energy because I trust that more than I trust slowing everything down and becoming mired in a, you know, a process of trying to find some elusive solution.
，相信你的品味、你的直觉，你可以相信自己的直觉，你的打击率会比大多数人高。如果你需要帮助，你会环顾四周去获得它，因为你没有多少时间可以浪费。让我们弄清真相并解决它。你开始信任那种节奏。当然，这就是我成长所经历的；所以，你知道，当我拍摄时，我喜欢以相当不错的节奏拍摄。我喜欢，你知道，我喜欢充满活力，因为我更相信这一点，而不是相信放慢一切并陷入试图找到某种难以捉摸的解决方案的过程中。
Do you think that if your dad was, I don't know, a doctor, you'd be a doctor? Or do you think you would always have had this passion, somehow this passion would have found you? That is amazing. If my dad was a doctor, I would be a doctor. If he'd stayed on the farm, I probably would have been on the farm. You know, he left the farm to chase this dream. My mom left this little town in Duncan, Oklahoma. But because I don't have a performer's personality exactly, I don't think I would have sought that out. I think once I was a part of it, I began to see this whole experience as something that suited me. I think I might have sought leadership. So I think I would have, I often
你觉得如果你父亲是个，我不知道，医生，你也会是个医生吗？还是你觉得你一直都会有这种激情，某种程度上这种激情会找到你？这太神奇了。如果我父亲是个医生，我就会是个医生。如果他留在农场，我可能也会留在农场。你知道，他离开农场是为了追逐这个梦想。我妈妈离开了俄克拉荷马州邓肯那个小镇。但因为我并没有那种表演型人格，我不认为我会主动去寻求那个。我想一旦我加入了进去，我开始把这段经历看作是适合我的事情。我想我可能会去寻求领导地位。所以我认为我会，我经常
thought I would have either been a, you know, like a... You would have ran the hospital. Well, yeah, not, my dad wasn't smart enough to be a doctor and probably I'm not either. So I don't think we would have made it through med school, but, but I might have been an English teacher or a history teacher and, you know, the basketball coach or something like that. Wow. Something that could be seen as sort of, or heard as inside baseball or getting into the weeds about directing, I think it would qualify as okay, because you could apply
觉得自己要么会成为一个，你知道，像个……你会去管理医院。好吧，是的，不，我爸没聪明到能当医生，可能我也没那么聪明。所以我不认为我们能熬过医学院，但是，但我可能会成为一名英语老师或历史老师，你知道的，或者篮球教练之类的人。哇。有些东西可以被视为或者听起来像是内行话，或者深入探讨导演的细节，我认为这算是不错的，因为你可以将它
it to a lot of other things, which is people contributing, as you were saying, with ideas and that sometimes that can create more of a disruption than a benefit if that idea is simply just different as opposed to better. How do you manage that on the set? And then hopefully that, that answer won't bore those who are not in this business and they can apply that answer to things in life. I think, I think it does apply. Really basically boils down to this, when people begin to trust that I'm actually happy to say yes to their idea, they're also then comfortable with no, because they do want
应用到许多其他事情上，也就是大家所说的贡献想法，有时候，如果这个想法仅仅是与众不同而不是更好，它带来的干扰可能会大于益处。你在片场是如何处理这种情况的？希望这个回答不会让那些不在这一行的人感到无聊，他们可以把这个回答应用到生活中的事情上。我想，我想这确实适用。基本上归结为一点：当人们开始相信我其实很乐意对他们的想法说“是”时，他们对于听到“不”也就感到自适了，因为他们确实需要一个领导者，你知道的，无论是一个公司的首席执行官、
a leader, you know, and whether it's the, you know, CEO of a company or, or a store manager or the director of the show or movie. The other thing is, because there is a kind of chaos that can set in when, you know, you open up your channels to so many voices. There are times when you just have to say, no, okay, no, just, just, we're just going to do this. Now let's just do that. And people have to be willing to accept it, but I find that they do.
还是商店经理、或是节目或电影的导演。另一件事是，因为当向太多声音敞开心扉时，确实会产生一种混乱。有时候你就是不得不说，不，好吧，不，我们就，我们就要这样做。现在我们就这样做。人们必须愿意接受这一点，但我发现他们确实会接受。
The other thing is, I have what I call a six of one rule, which is if a person's note, a significant person, the person who has to execute it, say a cinematographer, say an actor, say a composer, if they have an idea and it's different, but it achieves the objective, my job is to keep track of the objectives, what the story needs. And my instinct over the years or my, my observation has been, if you let the artist who you're guiding apply that choice that they intuitively understand well enough to make the suggestion that there's a next factor in that. And as long as it doesn't derail, go with that.
另一件事是，我有一个所谓的“六个对半打”规则，也就是说，如果一个人的意见，一个重要的人，也就是必须执行它的人，比如摄影师、演员、作曲家，如果他们有一个想法，虽然不同，但达到了目标，我的工作就是追踪目标，即故事需要什么。多年来我的直觉或我的观察是，如果你让你所指导的艺术家应用他们凭直觉理解得足够好、足以提出建议的选择，其中就会有一个后续因素。只要它不脱轨，就顺着那个来。
Now as long as it doesn't derail, and that's the judgment call that the director has to make and sometimes try it. And that's not just patronizing. That's let's, let's see what that does. And it's worth it. It's worth a take to see what it does to the scene. And sometimes it's no, that doesn't work, you know, do you find that exhilarating sometimes when somebody suggests something that you're like, well, that's not necessarily the way
只要它不脱轨，这就是导演必须做出的判断，有时甚至去尝试。这不仅仅是居高临下的敷衍。这是让我们看看这会带来什么效果。这值得拍一个镜头来看看它对场景有什么影响。有时候答案是“不，那不管用”，你知道，你有时会觉得很兴奋吗，当有人提出了一个你觉得“嗯，那不一定是我看待它的方式，
I'd look at it. But yeah, let's try it that way. And it comes up in a way that you wouldn't have imagined you find that every time the magic of that. Yeah. I mean, that's a great thing. Well, I mean, I, I mean, everybody likes to be right. So I enjoy that too.
但好吧，让我们那样试试”的想法，并且它的呈现方式是你绝对想象不到的，你每次都会发现其中的魔力。是的。我的意思是，那是一件棒极了的事。好吧，我的意思是，每个人都喜欢自己是对的。所以我也很享受这一点。
But what if it adds three hours of coverage though? Well, it depends on your day to have the budget. If you have the budget to say, we're going over team, you know, Ron, Jason's whole thing when he's directing is whatever decision he's, he always says, whatever gets me back on the 10 quicker, you know what I mean? Whatever it is, Jason's actors adore him. And so I hear actors talk, actors talk, you know, it's just, it's always that, it's always that judgment call.
但如果这多花三个小时的补拍时间呢？好吧，这取决于你的日程和预算。如果你有预算说，我们要超时了，你知道，朗，杰森执导时的全部做法就是，无论他做什么决定，他总是说，什么能让我更快回到十码线上，你知道我的意思吗？无论是什么，杰森的演员们都崇拜他。所以我听到演员们在谈论，演员们总是聊这些，你知道，这总是那种权衡，总是那种判断。
And sometimes it's, we just don't have time or we're going to, you know, we're going to lose it. But again, if, if people know what the objectives are, also the other big thing, the fun thing is when people are pulling in the same direction, they, you know, it starts to be a unified journey. And they feel everyone feels like they've got some ownership over the process and they're not just being told to do stuff as soldiers. I mean, what you were asking for examples, I mean, so many times, I'll tell you one is
有时情况是，我们就是没有时间，或者我们要，你知道的，我们要失去它了。但同样地，如果人们知道目标是什么，另一个重大事情，好玩的事情是，当大家朝着同一个方向努力时，你知道，它就开始成为一段统一的旅程。每个人都觉得他们对这个过程拥有某种所有权，他们不仅仅是被当作士兵被指挥去做事。我的意思是，你刚才要例子，有太多次了，我告诉你一个
kind of interesting. No, no, no. Tell us something super boring. Okay. Oh, maybe it's boring. You guys will judge. When Tom Hanks was doing Splat, and that's what I knew. I mean, he was a well trained and all of that, but, and he came in and he was sort of supposed
挺有意思的。不，不，不。给我们讲点超级无聊的事吧。好吧。哦，也许这很无聊。你们来评判吧。当汤姆·汉克斯在拍《现代美人鱼》时，这就是我所知道的。我的意思是，他受过良好的训练等等，但他进来时，他差不多应该成为这部电影的清白男主角，也就是电影中浪漫喜剧的那部分。
to be the straight man of this movie that's kind of the romantic comedy side of the movie. Eugene Levy and John Candy were the comedy. And Tom, I was really cautious about him maintaining his credibility at all times, and he's funny and he was trying to invent, but I felt like he was sort of trying to keep up with Eugene and John when I really needed him to just be rock solid. And you know, as I told him, the main thing is you just got to love the girl, but I would let him try things and little bits and so forth. And when I got to the editing room, I underestimated this guy.
尤金·列维和约翰·坎迪负责喜剧。而汤姆，我真的很小心地让他始终保持可信度，他很有趣，他一直在即兴发挥，但我感觉他有点在试图跟上尤金和约翰的节奏，而我真正需要的是他稳如磐石。而且正如我告诉他的，最主要的是你只需要爱上那个女孩，但我会让他尝试各种事情和一些小桥段等等。等我到了剪辑室，我低估了这个家伙。
I love these things. So on the day, I might have felt like I was just kind of letting him have a take. But I remember saying, if I ever get to work with Tom again, I'm going to, I'm really, I'm going to invite a lot more of this and how many films have you end up doing with him? A half a dozen? Maybe? Yeah, five, five.
我喜欢这些东西。所以在当时，我可能觉得我只是在让他多拍一个镜头。但我记得我说过，如果我以后还有机会和汤姆合作，我一定要，我真的，我要邀请更多这种发挥。你最后和他合作了多少部电影？半打左右？也许吧？对，五部，五部。
Wow. It's funny. It brings up Mitch Hurwitz, which is we were shooting Arrested Development. I think it was maybe season two, and we shot this scene where Tony Hale's character was coming back from prison, right? Was he coming back from prison or he's coming back from war? I forget what Arrested fans are going to be like, how dare you not remember? But there was this scene and there was this banner that said, welcome home.
哇。这很有趣。这让我想起了米奇·赫维茨，我们在拍《发展受阻》时。我想那可能是第二季，我们拍了这样一场戏：托尼·海尔饰演的角色从监狱里出来，对吧？他是从监狱里出来还是从战地回来？我忘了《发展受阻》的粉丝们会说，你们怎么敢不记得？但有这么一场戏，有一个横幅上面写着“欢迎回家”。
And we were shooting the scene and I said to him, I was holding onto Jason, like Jason comes in and I go, look at banner, Michael, like as if Job had lost all sort of sense of like syntax and grammar and everything. I just took all the words out of it and I just said, look at banner. And I was giddy and acting like an idiot, right? And I was doing it to make Jason laugh in the scene, right? So a couple of days later we're shooting across the street over at Rancho in the park there and I get a call.
我们在拍这场戏时，我对他说，我抓着杰森，杰森走过来，我说，看横幅，迈克尔，就好像杰布失去了对句法、语法和一切概念的感知一样。我把里面所有的词都去掉了，只说了句“看横幅”。我当时欣喜若狂，像个白痴一样表演，对吧？我这么做是为了在戏里逗杰森笑，对吧？所以几天后我们在对面拉奇牧场那边的公园里拍摄，我接到了一个电话。
Chuck Martin's got the phone, he's the onset producer and he goes, it's Mitch calling for you. I said, oh, shit. Okay. And Mitch goes, I'm in editing right now and every take, you're doing this stupid fucking thing, which he never kind of mad at me about it taking, because you're doing this stupid thing and it goes every single take, there's not one where you're not doing this thing where you're going crazy about look at banner.
查克·马丁拿着电话，他是现场制片人，他说，米奇打电话找你。我说，哦，靠。好吧。然后米奇说，我现在在剪辑室，每一个镜头，你都在做这个蠢透了的事情——他从来没因为我多拍而对我生气——因为你在做这个蠢事，而且他说每一个镜头，没有一个镜头是你没有做出那种发疯似的大喊“看横幅”的事情。
And I go, and I was like, man, I'm so sorry. And then on the way home, I was driving back out to Venice that we wrapped and I called Mitch and I go, man, I've been thinking about this all day. I'm so fucking sorry. He's like, yeah, it's okay. He really bummed me out. He puts the show together. He edits it and he calls me and he goes, I was so wrong.
我说，我当时就想，兄弟，我太抱歉了。然后在我回家的路上，我开车回威尼斯海滩，我们在那里收工了，我给米奇打电话说，兄弟，我一整天都在想这件事。我太他妈抱歉了。他说，好吧，没关系。他真的让我很沮丧。他把节目剪辑好，然后打电话给我说，我大错特错了。
I'm so sorry. It's the funniest moment in the whole episode. It was so good. I was so wrong. And I was like, and I spent like, it was about two months of feeling really shitty about like a choice. And it's one of the iconic lines for me it is. But God bless Mitch.
我太抱歉了。这是整集里最好笑的时刻。太棒了。我大错特错了。我当时就想，我花了大约两个月时间，因为一个选择而感到非常糟糕。对我来说，这是标志性的台词之一。但上帝保佑米奇。
He called me to say like, he was literally, I was wrong. And that was that thing. Like he hadn't seen it. It's just reminding me of that. Like he hadn't seen it in context and, you know. Right. Right. Yeah.
他打电话给我说，他真的，我错了。就是那样一回事。就像他以前没在语境中看过它，你知道的。对。对。对。
I always joke. I want to wear back to Tom Hanks, wear a bracelet that says WWTHD. What would Tom Hanks do? Because I think we all kind of seek our mentors or the people we want to emulate and we kind of use their path as a guide for our own. And I always thought when Tom, you know, was such a huge start still is and started Play Tone as a production company. I was like, hmm, how did he do that?
我总是开玩笑。我想戴一个手镯，上面写着“WWTHD”——汤姆·汉克斯会怎么做？因为我觉得我们都在寻找我们的导师或我们想要效仿的人，我们把他们的道路作为我们自己的指南。我一直认为，当汤姆，你知道，曾经是、现在仍然是一个超级巨星，并创立了 Playtone 作为制作公司时，我在想，嗯，他是怎么做到的？
And then, you know, it's kind of like, and you were actually truthfully an inspiration for me too. Like how just imagine entertainment became this thing, this massive, you know. It's one of the first ones, if not the first. Yeah. But a talent driven company. World driven, you know, Rob Reiner had a company at roughly the same time, Castle Rock. And you know, and there were others.
然后，你知道，这有点像，而你实际上也确实给了我启发。比如“想象娱乐”是如何变成这样一个庞然大物的。它是第一批之一，如果不是第一家的话。对。但一家以人才为驱动的公司。以世界为驱动，你知道，罗布·莱纳大约在同一时期也有一家公司，城堡岩（Castle Rock）。你知道，还有其他人。
I always. Danny DeVito, Penny Marshall. Yes. That's right. I had a small company even while I was still with Happy Days and I was producing and directing TV movies in the off season. So I was always sort of interested, you know, in that aspect of it. And it was a way to, a way to have control and to really learn about it.
我总是。丹尼·德维托，佩姬·马歇尔。是的。没错。甚至在我还在《欢乐时光》的时候，我就有一家小公司，我在淡季制作和导演电视电影。所以我一直对那方面很感兴趣。这也是一种掌控全局并真正了解它的方式。
Brian and I, so, you know, we clicked on Night Shift and then Splash. And we really are, you know, we're very, we're different in terms of like where our area of focus is, our personalities, of course, are really, really different. And but we just had this, this shared ambition. And we thought that it was pretty simple by pooling our efforts. It was more of an alliance almost than anything else. You'd A, have somebody with as much ambition as you, who's also got your back, you know, and somehow one plus one would be for more than two.
布莱恩和我，你知道，我们在《夜班巡逻》和《现代美人鱼》一拍即合。我们的确，你知道，我们在关注的领域、性格上都有很大不同，当然，我们的性格真的非常非常不同。但是我们有着共同的雄心。我们觉得这其实很简单，通过汇聚我们的力量。与其说别的，不如说这更像是一个联盟。A，你有一个和你一样有雄心的人，他也能为你撑腰，你知道，不知何故，一加一大于二。
And we could collect projects. So there was a lot less scrambling around, driving around town and a lot more focused problem solving. And it's, it's just, the company has changed so much. I mean, it's in the last couple of years, we are now, it's a different kind of business model because we're not attached to a studio or a single network. And it allows us to sort of nurture ideas and then find the best home for it, whether you're launching a bunch of talent too, right?
我们可以积累项目。这样在城里四处奔走、争夺资源的次数就少得多了，而更有针对性的问题解决则更多了。而且，公司的变化太大了。我的意思是，在过去的几年里，我们现在是一种不同的商业模式，因为我们不依附于某个制片厂或单一电视网。这让我们能够孕育创意，然后为之找到最好的归宿，无论你同时也在推出一大批人才，对吧？
Still anthropic. Yeah. Yeah. Through impact. A writer's content acceleration program. And when I say content, it's movies and television that we're, that we're doing, but we have a branded group. We have a documentary group.
依然是人类学导向。对。对。通过 Impact 计划。这是一个作家的内容加速计划。当我说内容时，指的是我们在做的电影和电视，但我们有一个品牌化的小组。我们有一个纪录片小组。
We have a kids and family group in addition to, you know, movies and television. And it's just, we're taking on more and more collaborators, really. Brian and I still have our sleeves rolled up and are still doing the stuff that we love, but it's, we're creating a kind of support system for, you know, for others to get things done. My first real memory of Imagine, just to bring it back to like my own experience was coming out to California to do the final test audition for Arrested Development. And I remember I had a really bad cold and I tested at Fox and they said that you want
除了电影和电视之外，我们还有一个儿童和家庭小组，而且，我们正在吸纳越来越多的合作者。布莱恩和我仍然卷起袖子，依然在做我们热爱的事情，但是，我们在为其他人创造一种支持系统，以便把事情做好。我对“想象娱乐”的第一个真正记忆，把它拉回到我自己的经验，就是来到加州参加《发展受阻》的最终试镜。我记得我当时得了很严重的感冒，我在福克斯试镜，他们说希望你来演这个试播集。
you to do the pilot. And I remember we went over to Imagine that next day to do a table read to your old office there at the corner. And I remember I was one of the first people to arrive and I went into this conference room at your office and I kind of looked out over and the last like few days had been such a whirlwind and office, I lived in New York when I found myself, I'm like, what am I doing? I'm here in the Imagine office of Ron Howard and Brian Grazer and I'm looking and I'm
我记得第二天我们去了“想象娱乐”在街角的旧办公室做剧本围读。我记得我是最早到达的人之一，我走进了你们办公室的会议室，我环顾四周，过去几天就像是一场旋风，办公室，我住在纽约，当发现自己身处那里时，我在想，我在干什么？我在这里，在朗·霍华德和布莱恩·格雷泽的“想象”办公室里，我正看着，我身处洛杉矶的中心，我即将做这件事。
in the middle of LA and I'm about to do this thing. And I could feel my life changing in that moment. I swear to God, I knew it was different. I knew there was something different about that script, about that cast, about all of it. And that was a huge moment in my life. It changed everything for me. Yeah, I remember getting the script for Arrested Development and the cover page said, you know,
我能感觉到我的生活在那一刻改变了。我向上帝发誓，我知道它不一样了。我知道那个剧本、那个演员阵容以及所有这一切都有所不同。那是我生命中一个巨大的时刻。它改变了我的一切。是的，我记得拿到《发展受阻》的剧本时，封面写着，你知道，
any actors that need to be basically pampered, I'm paraphrasing here, need not apply because this is going to be done in sort of a mockumentary style. There's not really going to be a lot of marks on the floor or lights or dressing rooms or it's kind of going to be running gun and then I read it and it was so sort of punk rock in its comedy approach and its mockumentary style. And the fact that it was an Imagine project and that you, Ron, were going to be the narrator and basically stamping this thing was so ominous to me. At that moment, I had so much sort of multi-camera sitcom baggage on me and one of my ex-agents
任何需要被娇惯的演员——我在这里是意译——都不用来申请，因为这将以伪纪录片风格拍摄。地上不会有很多标记或灯光或化妆间，它将是一种游击式拍摄，然后我读了它，它的喜剧手法和伪纪录片风格非常朋克摇杆。而且它是“想象”的项目，而你，朗，将成为旁白，基本上为这个项目盖章，这对我来说太震撼了。那一刻，我有太多的多机位情景喜剧包袱，我的一位前经纪人
actually was saying you should read for this and I said, it's such a cool project. I mean, with Ron Howard and the brand of the comedy, they're never going to want me to risk staining how sort of post kind of comedy this is and how cool it is. And fortunately, I'd auditioned for Mitch Hurwitz on something years and years earlier that he liked what I had done and so he said yes to having me read for it, but your stamp on that show and your continued stamp on it as being the voice of it all the way through was such a validator for I think audiences certainly in this town, which benefited all of us greatly while it wasn't as huge a hit as some of the bigger sort of comedies.
其实之前就说你应该去读读这个角色，我说，这项目太酷了。我是说，有朗·霍华德和这种喜剧风格，他们绝对不会想冒风险去玷污这种后现代风格的喜剧以及它的酷炫。幸运的是，很多很多年前我曾为米奇·赫维茨的一个项目试镜，他挺喜欢我的表现，所以他同意让我去读剧本，但你对这部剧的烙印，以及你作为全剧旁白一直以来的烙印，对于观众来说——尤其是这个圈子里的人——绝对是一种巨大的肯定，这让我们所有人都受益匪浅，尽管它不像某些更大牌的喜剧那样是大爆款。
The people in this town watched it and that really, really helped us when the show was over in our ability to get re-hired. So I just can't thank you enough. It was a great experience. I'm sorry, Ron. I know you had a heart out two hours ago. Sorry about that. I know.
这个圈子里的人都看了，当剧集结束时，这真的、真的在我们需要重新找到工作时帮了大忙。所以我对你感激不尽。那是一段很棒的经历。对不起，朗。我知道你两小时前就有一个必须离开的硬性安排。真不好意思。我知道。
I'm okay. All right. Will and I are talking to dad. This is big for a man. Yeah. Totally good. But I got to say, it was when a rest of development clicked and by the way, I remember looking at your audition in my office and Mitch said, I think maybe Jason Bateman, take a look and
我没事。好了。我和我爸在聊天呢。这可是件大事。行啊。完全没问题。但我得说，就是在那时《发展受阻》渐入佳境，顺便说一句，我记得在我的办公室里看过你的试镜录看，米奇说，我觉得也许杰森·贝特曼可以看看，然后
I looked and I just started beaming because inside I was going, kid actors, rock on. Oh, that's great. I never knew that. That's great. So I was excited about that. But also from that very first pilot, the cast just clicked and then you clicked with Mitch's voice. Yeah.
我看了看，脸上立刻露出了笑容，因为我心里在想，童星太棒了。哦，太棒了。我从来不知道这件事。太棒了。所以我为此很兴奋。而且从最初的那集试镜开始，演员阵容就一拍即合，然后你和米奇的风格也契合了。是啊。
And the whole idea was supposed to be much more improv, which you guys did some of and you always sort of had a green light, but mostly you were sticking to the script. You couldn't better his writing. And it was just going and you might not remember, but initially the pilot didn't have any voice over. Oh, really? And we did it. And Mitch said, you know how you always thought about voiceover and you always pitch that?
而且整个想法本来应该是更多的即兴表演，你们确实做了一些，而且你们也一直算是有绿灯权限，但大多数时候你们还是在照着剧本演。你没法超越他的剧本。事情就这样推进着，你可能不记得了，但最初的试镜集是没有旁白的。哦，真的吗？我们做完了。然后米奇说，你知道你以前怎么看待旁白、怎么一直提议这个的吗？
Maybe we should try it. And I said, okay. And I was literally shooting. I was shooting a Western in Santa Fe. So Mitch sent me this stuff with a cut. And at lunchtime, I got in the sound guy's truck and just laid down the lines and sent it back. So Mitch called me like about a week later and he says, well, I've got either good news
也许我们该试试。我说，好吧。我当时正在拍戏。我正在圣达菲拍一部西部片。所以米奇把剪辑好的东西连同素材发给了我。在午休时间，我钻进录音师的卡车里，直接把台词录完然后发了回去。所以大约一周后米奇打电话给我，他说，嗯，我有好消息
and good news or good news and bad news. I don't know what it is. And what do you want? I said, well, I want the good, good. And that leaves off in both instances. And he said, okay, the show tested really well. It went just great. And I said, okay, so what's the bad or good?
加好消息，或者好消息加坏消息。我也不知道这算什么。你想听哪个？我说，嗯，我想要那个好的，好的。这两种情况结果都一样。然后他说，好吧，这部剧测试反响非常好。效果棒极了。我说，好吧，那坏的或者好的消息是什么？
He said, the narrator was the highest testing thing, highest testing element in the pilot. You have to do it. It must have been a big pain in the ass for you to have to fit it in all the time with all the work you were doing. It was a pain in the ass and a blast. What was the craziest place? Can you remember? You had to do voiceover for the show in a shack where they had to like put sound blankets
他说，旁白是反响最热烈的环节，是试镜集中反响最好的元素。你必须得录。你一直得在拍戏之余抽空去弄这些，这一定让你觉得很头疼吧？确实头疼，但也超爽。最疯狂的地方是哪里？你还记得吗？你得在某个棚屋里为这部剧录旁白，他们得像那样把隔音毯
up and the wind was howling. What country was that in? Let's see. What country was that in? Well, I guess it was in, it was actually in Canada. It was in Canada. And it's outside. It's in the middle of the night.
挂起来，外面狂风呼啸。那是在哪个国家？让我想想。那是在哪个国家？嗯，我想那是在，其实是在加拿大。是在加拿大。而且是在户外。那是大半夜。
And Louise and my assistant say, they need this. They need the track. And I'm reading this and you know, oh, I think we heard the wind on that last one, Ron. Try it again. But here's the thing. From the moment the show aired, even though it wasn't rating smash, it was qualifying. It was quality and it was original and it was breakthrough. And I thought, wow, I've actually been involved in three great shows now.
露易丝和我的助理说，他们需要这个。他们需要这条音轨。我正在读台词，你知道的，哦，我想我们在最后一句里听到风声了，朗。再试一次。但关键是。从这部剧播出的那一刻起，尽管它收视率不是大爆，但它够格。它有品质，有原创性，具有突破性。我想，哇，我实际上已经参与过三部伟大的剧了。
How many people can say that? Yeah. And because it was a great show in that, like the last cycle of the Netflix versions of Arrested Development, I've suddenly started showing up playing myself. This is embarrassing for Sean, by the way, because he's famously never seen Arrested Development. Two of his best friends are on the show. It's stunning.
有多少人能这么说呢？对啊。而且因为它是一部伟大的剧，就像《发展受阻》Netflix版本的最后一个周期一样，我突然开始出现并扮演我自己。顺便说一句，肖恩这下尴尬了，因为众所周知他从未看过《发展受阻》。他最好的两个朋友就在这部剧里。这太惊人了。
And so he, I was waiting for him to hang himself. And now you, so, so sorry, Ron, keep, continue. Tell Sean about your role in Arrested Development. Wait a minute, Jason, tell them when we were reading copy the other week, what I did, what did I call it? Oh God, he said, I think, did you say gob? I said gob, yeah. By the way, it's in the commercial.
所以我，我一直在等着他自己出丑。而现在你，所以，对不起，朗，继续。跟肖恩讲讲你在《发展受阻》里的角色。等等，杰森，告诉他们前几周我们读台词的时候，我做了什么，我把它叫什么？天哪，他说，我想，你是不是说gob？我说gob，对。顺便说一句，这还在广告里呢。
Oh good. It's on the air, one of our commercials, he mispronounces my character and goes, he'll just remain like gob and Jason goes, all right, do you mean Job? I think, and he's like, no, what is this gob thing? And they, the boys kept it in the commercial. It's so good. They say, they say it holds up Sean. I think you might want to check it out.
太好了。正在播呢，在我们的一个广告里，他把我的角色的名字读错了，说，他将永远作为gob留在那里，而杰森说，等等，你是说Job（乔布）？我想，然后他就像是，不，这个gob是什么鬼？然后，他们，那群小伙子把它保留在广告里了。太棒了。他们说，他们说这剧经得起时间的检验，肖恩。我想你可能得去看看。
No, I know it does. But anyway, so, so now I've got to do these three days of playing myself, which again, doesn't quite count as acting, but there are written, there's written dialogue, you know, and there's sort of a cadence and a rhythm and some things are supposed to be set ups or jokes. And I realized, and all my scenes, fortunately, are all with Jason. And because I'm starting and they're saying action and I'm doing it and I could see Jason look at me and say, oh my God, he's fucked.
不，我知道经得起。但总之，所以——现在我得花三天时间扮演我自己，这再次说明，这虽然不太算演戏，但有现成的台词，你知道的，有一种语调和节奏，有些东西本该是铺垫或笑话。我意识到，而且我的所有戏份，幸运的是，都是和杰森一起拍的。因为我开拍了，他们喊了“开始”，我在演，我能看到杰森看着我，心想：“天哪，他死定了。”
No, not like when I looked at Brian, when I looked at Brian, I was like, oh, baby. But I could kind of remember the lines, but not really. But I had no, there were no gears. I couldn't find the clutch, let alone the gear shift. You faked it well then. Well, but I, I sort of soldier through that first day. And you know, by day three, I felt like, okay, I kind of, it's a little like riding a bike. Where's my chair?
不，不像我看着布莱恩时那样，当我看着布莱恩时，我是觉得，哦，宝贝。但我也许能记住台词，但不是真的记住。不过我完全没有挡位。我连离合器都找不到，更别说换挡了。那你当时装得挺像那么回事的。嗯，不过我，我算是硬着头皮熬过了第一天。你知道的，到了第三天，我觉得，好吧，我大概，这有点像骑自行车。我的椅子在哪儿？
Yeah. Oh, I wouldn't mind acting. I'd like to act. Do you remember sort of your process, pardon the term, as an actor enough to feel like you are as good as you want to or need to be as a director when you direct actors and basically talking their language, remembering enough of your process as an actor? Huge asset for me. Yeah.
对啊。哦，我不介意演戏。我想演戏。作为一名演员，你还记得你的创作过程吗——请原谅我用这个词——当你作为导演去指导演员时，你是否觉得自己足够好，达到了你想达到或需要达到的水平，能够和他们用同一种语言交流，还能记住足够多作为演员时的创作过程？这对我是巨大的财富。对。
Major asset. In fact, I've had to really school myself on all the other sort of tools in the director's kit, you know, because I've learned to be a better visualist. I've learned to understand the rhythm of scenes and how sound and music can really affect it and so forth. Because my go-to was always, always the actors and to this day, I feel like the one thing you can really count on is a well executed, well acted moment. You know, it'll always propel your story forward.
重大的财富。事实上，我不得不真正地训练自己去掌握导演工具箱里的所有其他工具，你知道的，因为我学会了成为一个更有视觉表现力的人。我学会了理解场景的节奏，以及声音和音乐如何真正地影响它，诸如此类。因为我最拿手的始终是，永远都是演员，直到今天，我觉得你真正能指望的，就是一个执行到位、演技出色的时刻。你知道的，它总能推动你的故事向前发展。
So you know, that means a lot. Rob Reiner told me, I directed him in Ed TV, came back and he said, oh, you should try acting again. I found that I was, you know, I was what I was then I'm much better now having directed so many great people. And when I was acting, I was such a dutiful soldier and I kind of narrow as to the way in which I would try to deliver. And I think if I really was trying to act again and really focused on it, I think I
所以你知道的，这意义重大。罗伯·莱纳曾对我说过，我在《艾德·TV》里导演过他，他回来后说，哦，你应该再尝试演戏。我发现我当时，你知道的，我当时是什么样就是什么样，而现在我好多了，因为导演了那么多优秀的人。而当我演戏时，我是一个如此听话的士兵，而且对于我试图呈现的方式非常狭隘。我想如果我真的再次尝试演戏并全神贯注于此，我想我
would draw upon experiences with the, you know, Hanks and Russell Crow, Kate Blanchett and Amy Adams and Glenn Close and people like that who I've had, because I've seen them take things to another level without changing the script, without riffing anything. They just find these nuances and things that I don't think I ever had. Even the awareness that I should be necessarily looking for that when I was a young man. I remember sitting behind you in the screening of a, sorry, the Kate Blanchett movie is called The Missing. Yeah, The Missing.
会借鉴与那些人的合作经验，你知道的，汉克斯、罗素·克劳、凯特·布兰切特、艾米·亚当斯、格伦·克洛斯以及其他我曾合作过的人，因为我见识过他们如何在不改动剧本、不进行任何即兴发挥的情况下，将表演提升到另一个高度。他们只是找到了那些微小的细节和东西，而这些是我认为自己从来不具备的。甚至在我年轻时，我都不知道自己必须去寻找这些东西。我记得有一次坐在你身后看一部电影的试映，抱歉，那部凯特·布兰切特的电影叫《失踪》。对，《失踪》。
I was sitting right behind you in that screening. That was such a long, long, long time ago in the Paramount lot. And I was like, oh my God, I'm sitting right behind Ron Howard. This is crazy. And he just directed the movie we're about to watch. And then it was over, you turn around and you said, what did you think? I go, is it locked? And you were like, so not in the mood.
我就坐在那场试映的你身后。那是很久很久以前在派拉蒙片场的事了。当时我就想，天哪，我正坐在朗·霍华德身后。这太疯狂了。他刚刚执导了我们马上要看的这部电影。然后电影结束了，你转过身来说，你觉得怎么样？我说，定剪了吗？而你当时那种表情，就好像完全没心情。
You're like, oh, this is fucking an idiot, like a funny man has to say something funny. You mentioned Amy Adams and Glenn Close. I've seen Hillbilly Elegy. Thank you for letting me see that. It's such a great movie. Do you care a ton about whether your film is in a theater versus streaming? They said, if you do care negatively about it, is that a bigger negative than the positive that having streaming gives us all in that there's more content, more films, more opportunities
你当时就像是，哦，这真是个大笨蛋，搞喜剧的人非得说点搞笑的话。你提到了艾米·亚当斯和格伦·克洛斯。我看过《乡下人的悲歌》。谢谢你让我看了那部电影。那是部多么棒的电影啊。你在乎你的电影是在影院上映还是在流媒体上线吗？他们说，如果你对此持消极态度，那这种消极影响是否大于流媒体带给我们的积极影响——比如有更多内容、更多电影、更多就业机会以及更多观看节目的机会？你对这一切持什么立场？
for employment and more opportunities to see stuff? Where do you stand on all that? I come down on the side of the latter, ultimately, if it really is a binary decision. I really hope and I don't believe that the large screen shared experience is going to entirely vanish. I think it's going to change. I think it has changed and it will continue to. But I do think that's a unique experience and maybe it becomes kind of like the hard
如果这真的是一个二选一的决定，我最终还是会倾向于后者。我真的希望，而且我不相信大银幕的共同观影体验会彻底消失。我认为它会改变。我认为它已经改变了，并且还将继续改变。但我确实认为那是一种独特的体验，也许它会变得有点像小说的精装书出版发行一样。但我永远会重视并珍惜这一点。不过在我整个职业生涯中，在电视上看过我拍的电影的人，永远比在电影院看的人多，哪怕是在电影超级大卖的时候。但它会影响你的创作过程吗？比如你构图特写镜头的方式？如果你考虑到的是更小的设备，你可能会用更紧凑的特写，或者因为房间里的环境光与影院不同，而调整你的光照水平和对比度？不会了，不会。
cover publishing release for a novel. But I'll always value that and cherish that. But in my entire career, more people have seen the movies I've made on TV than ever in the movie, even when they were massive hits. But does it affect your creative process, the way in which you might frame a close-up? If you're thinking about a smaller device, you might have a tighter close-up or in your light levels in contrast because of ambient light in a room versus a theater? Not anymore, no.
我是说，当我拍电视电影的时候，你必须这样做，因为那真的是一种不同的格式。但现在，如果你在拍电视剧，你可以用2比1的比例。从格式和屏幕比例来看，它非常像185。我不会，我告诉你为什么。因为当我刚开始拍电视电影时，我听到很多关于某种特定取景和某种特定构图的说法，在那个年代，如果你想看一部经典电影，你必须在电视指南里找到它，然后要么设置定时器，要么醒来去看。
I mean, when I was doing TV movies, you had to because it was really a different format. But now, if you're doing TV, you could do it two to one. And it looks very much like 185 in terms of format and screen ratio. I don't and I'll tell you why. Because when I first began doing TV movies and I was hearing a lot about certain kind of coverage and certain kind of composition, in those days, if you wanted to watch a classic movie, you had to find it in the TV guide and then either put on the timer or wake up and watch it.
没错。所以，我已经很久很久没看过《愤怒的葡萄》了，那是约翰·福特的经典之作。我真的很想再看一遍。当时刚好在我上夜班的时候播出。我们在拍《欢乐的日子》的夜戏。所以我跑回我的房车。我有一台小黑白电视，我是说，真的，大概只有两英寸大。我打开《愤怒的葡萄》看了几分钟。
Right. And so, I hadn't seen Grapes of Wrath in a long, long time, John Ford classic. And I really wanted to see it again. And it happened to be coming on during night shooting. We were doing some nights on happy days. And so, I ran to my trailer. I had a little black and white TV, I mean, literally, like probably two inches. And I put on Grapes of Wrath and I watched a few minutes of it.
而且我在大银幕上看这片子好几次了。我说，那些家伙太疯狂了。哪怕是在两英寸的屏幕上，约翰·福特的构图依然奏效。哇。对啊。所以，就照着这个来吧。这就是我一直在做的事情。当然，放到今天，你知道的。
And I'd seen it on big screen a few times. And I said, those guys are crazy. Even on two inches, John Ford's composition works. Wow. Yeah. And so, go with that. And that's pretty much what I've been here doing. And today, of course, you know.
家里的屏幕很大。嗯，家里的屏幕很大，而且拍摄更快，布光更快。《黑钱胜地》看起来就像电影。它不只像电影。一切都能转化。所以，我记得我们当时在Netflix上合作我们的剧《爱登堡》，和Wally Fister（瓦利·费斯特）一起。Wally在当导演，但当我们在为剧集定基调时，他正在设置这个镜头。
Home screens are big. Well, home screens are big and photography's quicker, lighting's faster. You know, Ozark looks like a movie. It's not like a movie. It all translates. So, I remember we were working on our show Flaked on Netflix and with Wally Fister. And Wally was directing, but he was setting up this shot as we were setting up the look for the show.
然后他说，他花了很长时间来设置这个镜头。最后我说，伟大的Wally Fister是一位伟大的摄影师，这一代最伟大的摄影师之一。而他正在设置镜头。我说，Wally，我很抱歉打扰你，老兄，人们会在地铁里、在手机上像这样看这部剧，就这样。然后他的肩膀垮了下来，低下了头，心想，好吧，你说得对。好吧，我们走吧。
And he goes, he was taking forever to set up this shot. And I said, finally, the great Wally Fister is a great cinematographer, one of the great cinematographers of this generation. And he was setting up the shot. And I said, Wally, I hate to break it to you, man, but people are going to be watching the show like this on the subway, on their phone, like this. And his shoulders slumped, and he hung his head, and he was like, yeah, you're right. All right, let's go.
嗯，我是说，有一件事，电视制作的档期不一定能允许你这样做，尽管，你知道的，克里斯，我是《黑钱胜地》的粉丝，所以我不是故意老提它，但我看了每一集，我都爱看，而且我特别喜欢你导演的那些集。包括，我还记得跟你聊过某种船上的镜头之类的，它从对面朝你们推过来，那是一个非常棒的镜头，非常有电影感。但这样的镜头少之又少。这正是你在拍电视剧时真正放弃的东西——那种控制白天的能力，
Well, I mean, one thing, the one thing that a TV schedule just doesn't necessarily afford you, although, you know, Chris, I'm an Ozark fan, so I don't mean to keep coming back to it, but I've watched every episode, and I love them, and I love the episodes you direct are particularly strong. Including, I remember talking to you about some kind of boat shot or something that pressed in on you guys from across, it was a fantastic shot, very much a movie shot. But those are few and far between. That's what you really do give up when you're directing television is that ability to control
这样你就能做一个漫长、棘手的布景，并在绝对完美的光线下把它拍出来，而在拍电影时，你有时是有机会做到这一点的。但在电视剧中，你必须不断推进，因为你有这个任务，你得像喂养一头野兽一样源源不断地供给。对，这只是预算上的差异，这就是我们谈到流媒体、电影和电影未来等等时所涉及的事情之一。流媒体正在带回来的事情之一，就是为这种由角色驱动的电影提供更好的预算。
the day so that you can do a lengthy, tricky setup and get it in exactly the right light and the kinds of things that, you know, on film, you're sometimes able to do. But in TV, you have to keep moving because you have this, you've got to feed the beast as it were a little bit. Yeah, it's just a budget difference, which is one of the things that, you know, talking about streamers and movies and the future of movies and so forth. One of the things that streamers is sort of bringing back is the better budget for character-driven movies.
对。它们允许一部由角色驱动的作品同时具有电影感。对。当你现在在流媒体上看到这些剧集时，它们能够用八集或十集的时间来讲故事，而不是区区两小时或九十分钟，能够深入其中讲述这个角色的故事并真正放慢节奏，你会不会也有那种羡慕嫉妒恨的感觉，心里想：操，我也好想用这种方式讲故事啊。
Yeah. They'll allow a character-driven piece to actually also be cinematic. Yeah. Do you have ever that kind of envy when you watch these shows now on the streamers where they're able to tell a story, not in two hours or 90 minutes, that they can tell a story over eight episodes or 10 episodes and really get in there and tell the story of this character and really take their time, is there part of you that goes like, shit, there's a, I'd love to tell a story this way.
我是说，我们有，这正是我们现在在Imagine公司正在做的事。想象一下。哦，抱歉。非常抱歉。肖恩，肖恩，去你妈的。对不起。我导演了《天才》的第一集，我们在国家地理频道做了一集，杰弗里·拉什扮演阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦。
I mean, we have, and that's what we're doing at Imagine now. Imagine that. Oh, sorry. I'm so sorry. Sean, Sean, go fuck yourself. I'm sorry. I directed the first episode of Genius, we did an episode on that geo with Jeffrey Rush playing Albert Einstein.
哦，对，我看了。太棒了。那对我来说就像是一次小小的尝试，体验一下仅仅通过一个纯粹的角色、让故事在八到十个小时里展开是多么美妙的感觉。你能想象自己拍八到十集吗？能。能。我能。
Oh, yeah, I saw it. It's great. And that was me kind of tasting how great it was to just do a pure character, let it unfold over eight or 10 hours. Could you see yourself doing eight or 10 episodes? Yeah. Yeah. I could.
在合适的情况下，我真的、真的可以。太棒了。快把你的家庭电话给我。一定要打给我。对。所以，朗，我只想说——非常感谢你能作客我们的节目。太好玩了。
Under the right circumstance, I really, really could. Great. Let me get your home number real quick. Please call. Yeah. So, Ron, I just want to say- Thank you so much for being with us. What a blast.
谢谢你能来。每次我见到你，你都给人一种最好奇、最美妙、最善良、最甜蜜、最慷慨的氛围，简直太棒了，难怪人人都想跟你合作。总有一天，你得告诉我你对谁发过脾火，因为我想看看那是什么样，不过我们可以下次再说。他们都死光了。但谢谢你能来。我还有十亿个问题，所以希望我们能再聚一次。
Thank you for being here. Every time I've met you, you are like the most curious, wonderful, kind, sweet, generous vibe about you that is just amazing to wonder everybody wants to work with you. One of these days, you're going to have to tell me who you've lost your temper on because I'd like to see that, but we can get that next time. They're all dead. But thank you for being here. I have a billion other questions, so hopefully we can do it again.
谢谢。这个播客太棒了。谢谢。现在我都上瘾了。我听这些是为了解你们在做什么。我彻底入坑了。对。这不过是三个书呆子罢了。
Thanks. And the podcast is great. Thank you. And now I'm addicted. I listened to them to kind of understand what you guys were doing. I'm in all the way. Yeah. It's just three dorks.
好吧，非常感谢你提升了节目的档次并和我们聊了这么久，希望我很快能再和你通话，老兄。很高兴见到你们。很高兴见到你，朗。很高兴见到你，朗。谢谢。拜拜。
Yeah. Well, thank you so much for classing this up and talking with us for a bit, and hopefully I'll talk to you soon, pal. Great to see you guys. Great to see you, Ron. Great to see you, Ron. Thank you. Bye-bye.
拜拜。哇。肖恩，你知道，我想说，首先，这嘉宾太棒了，而且我感觉挺内疚的，因为我觉得，你知道，我和杰森直接把场子接管了。我们只是想——你在开玩笑吗？这可是他的嘉宾。我知道。
Bye-bye. Wow. Sean, you know, I want to say, first of all, great guest, and I feel bad because I feel like, you know, Jason and I just took over. We just wanted to- Are you kidding me? It was his guest. I know.
他什么都没问。我太喜欢了。抱歉。我太喜欢了。杰森，我本来想说这个，当朗做客时，我记得早期当你开始做的时候，你开始真正仰视朗，你谈到了他和布莱恩在Imagine所做过的事。而且我觉得今天比以往任何时候都更能真正看出，你们之间有很多相似之处。
He didn't ask anything. I loved it. Sorry. I loved that. Jason, I was going to say this, when Ron was on, I remember early on when you started, you started really looking to Ron, and you were talking about what he and Brian had done and imagined. And I think even more today than ever, really see that there are a lot of similarities between
我能理解为什么他会成为行业黄金标准。他在整体创作上以及他所做过的成就上都是黄金标准——但除此之外，你可以把他看作是一个几乎带有导师角色的人，如果非要找个更好的词的话——因为他是一个——你们有着非常相似的轨迹，你们都在很小的年纪就开始作为演员工作。而他就是那种把这一点拿过来并不断改变、适应、转型去当导演的人，这正是你想要的。
you guys. I could see why he would be the gold standard. He's the gold standard in general for what he's done creatively and what he's- but also that you could look at him in a sort of almost a mentor role for lack of a better term because he's a guy who- you had very similar paths in that you've been both working as actors from a very young age. And he's somebody who took that and kept changing and adapting it and directing, which is what you wanted to.
你其实是——我本来想说，我不想让朗难堪，杰森是导演工会史上最年轻的会员。哦，我不知道这个。对，我不知道。这太酷了。不过我能理解。
You're the- in fact, I was going to say, I didn't want to shame Ron, Jason is the youngest ever member of the director's guild. Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah. I wonder if it still stands. Yeah, I don't know. That's pretty awesome. But I could see it.
而且——这真的太酷了。我比以往任何时候都更能理解你和朗之间的那种联系，我看到了，这很合情理。我一直都有这种感觉，甚至在他来做客之前，我一直觉得杰森·贝特曼就是另一个朗·霍华德。一直都是。对。
And- That's really awesome. I understand that connection that you have with Ron now more than ever and I saw it and it makes sense. I always felt that, but even before he came on, I always felt Jason Bateman was a Ron Howard. Always. Yeah.
对。而且我一直都说，肖恩，你就是一个山寨货。你知道我的意思吗？谢谢。谢谢。或者是一个唐·诺茨。或者唐·诺茨。天哪。
Yeah. And I've always said, and Sean, you're a buddy hack it. You know what I mean? Thank you. Thank you. Or a Don Knott's. Or a Don Knott's. Oh my God.
我试试。肖恩，你从来不——我希望你永远别看《发展受阻》。别威胁我。我真的这么想。你现在不配看。不过我真的、真的很好奇，如果你看了，它——我不觉得你会喜欢。它跟你想象的有哪怕一点点接近吗——因为我讨厌看这么晚才推出的东西。
I try it. Sean, you never- I hope you never watch a recipe development. Don't threaten me. I really do. You don't deserve it now. I'm really, really curious though, if you did, if it- I don't think you'll like it. Is anything near what you think- because I hate seeing stuff so late.
就像——我看过片段并且笑过——我看过片段。我看过片段。别说我看过片段。好吧。这就是我不想从你这里听到的。我不想听到，“我看过片段”。
Like- I've seen clips and laughed at- I've seen clips. I've seen clips. Don't say I've seen clips. Okay. This is what I don't want to hear from you. I don't want to hear, I've seen clips.
如果这是我这辈子干的最后一件事，我他妈也得把这破剧给看了。不，你不会的。不会的。除非里面有飞碟。斯科蒂看过吗？斯科蒂看过吗？哦，天哪。听着，重点是——
I'm gonna fucking watch this goddamn thing if it's the last thing I do. No, you won't. No. Not if there's not a flying saucer in it. Has Scotty watched it? Has Scotty ever seen it? Oh, bless. Look, the point is-
你知道吗？重点是，你可以花时间，就像我们一样，我们真的是好朋友，我们可以把世界上所有的精力和时间花在一起，但是，拜拜！拜拜！拜拜！拜拜！
You know what? The point is, you could spend, like, we are, we're really great friends, we could spend all the time in the world together, but, bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。